so you won't settle right
no okay
do you do go ahead
say what you got to say okay do you
think we're doing a good job with
marriage
nowadays and and dating in general do
you think people are finding what they
want in life
no no okay and would you agree that in
foreign countries maybe not necessarily
wherever you're from but like in other
places people marry
much more and they stay married for much
longer compared to how we do it here
yes okay so wouldn't you also
potentially agree
that maybe the way that we're doing
things is a little bit [ __ ] up
definitely okay and so if i were to ask
you what do you think is the largest
difference
between how we do things here and how
they do it in those countries where it
works
um what's the difference
well um i'm italian so one of the things
that i've noticed in italy is that once
you're married to get divorced is
basically unthinkable um because
of what i mentioned before and going
back to that
um once you marry someone and you make
those vows
not only marriage is a safety net but
you're also promising to work things out
with that person
so the belief in like divorcing doesn't
come as easy as
here where it's just like well let's
just get divorced
you know and it's basically like people
get married to get divorced
here like that is the goal you see what
i'm saying so so when you're living in a
foreign country when they get married
they're not just marrying the person
families are coming together you have a
whole social responsibility it's not
just me it's a community thing it's a
community thing here everything is about
how i feel and what i want and my
standards guess what over there they
don't talk about standards
you know we asked everyone here what
they wanted out of a marriage and people
were talking about we want to grow
together we want to do this you go to
foreign countries they don't talk about
those concepts
they don't talk about that take care of
the kids take care of me and make sure
that you don't stay in our family name
and then that's pretty much set
right and divorce is not even a concept
these
people settles like their standards are
very reasonable and they're very
at a good place and you know what they
end up married and they end up finding
somebody that works for them
i think i think i would hear people say
they won't settle
but the things that they won't settle on
aren't even important to making a
marriage last
like what do you guys think i was i was
interested in hearing what people were
saying like
what i bring to the table long term but
none of you really mentioned the things
that really matter to making something
work long term
nobody mentioned responsibility nobody
mentioned
uh duty right nobody mentioned just the
idea of
labor you yeah so i think people have
these unrealistic expectations when it
comes to long-term projects
right and they think it's you know going
to be cool and we're going to love each
other and there's going to be lots of
emotions and spiritualness and all this
other stuff
the truth is it's a lot of work go ask
people who've been together for a long
time they'd be like yo it's
work the wedding day is wonderful after
that you
every day you wake up the kids are
crying you don't get to sleep for days
you guys got all these bills piling up
people got to take second jobs
she's going through [ __ ] uh you know
the after effects of pregnancy there's
all kinds of complications it's a lot of
labor so when people come in they say
they're never gonna settle
i already feel like when you're coming
at this whole idea of marriage
especially on the things that you say
you won't settle on i'm like they're not
important to having a good and long
prosperous marriage
you know people talk about i want to be
in love with my husband but people get
divorced you know what they never
mentioned
love because they still love each other
it had nothing to do with why they got
divorced
they get divorced for financial reasons
right they get divorced maybe sometimes
because of infidelity
because you know what i'm just i don't
want to be with that person but love is
never a thing so i just think it's
interesting
that the things you guys need aren't the
reason that people get divorced
and aren't the things that keep people
staying together for a long time
no pun intended wow but abba is
preaching
he was you was you did that well i mean
it did that it was after our
conversation it was what it was
and to be fair these are things that
you've taught me that other old couples
have taught me that research shows
you know when researchers talk about
they talk about love in these concepts
right
they say that what makes couples love
each other the most is not the happy
moments
but how they come out of the very
difficult times
when you struggle together and come out
on the other side you're like that's a
soldier
they got my back so when we in the
trenches i could look to you and i know
i'm safe
if we couldn't normalize it
on [ __ ] that happened you know you sit
with your girl
and you're like yo we just had a baby
and i just want to tell you that
you did that you did that you
you you did that it was difficult it was
hard
but you did that now we have a baby now
but now i know it's not over
i know i know it's not done but
you handled that like a champ
and and and she could be doing the same
thing well we had a lot of
oh yo we just came out from this and
this and that and it was really hard but
we did that yo
i know that it was really hard with the
tax season with this and that and i was
still in school
and i'm done with school but you really
handled
you know i was i was not as much there
that i could with the kids because i had
to but you handled that
you had my back you had my back
like my parents never did that but i saw
that i saw that sometimes it was
something that happened
my dad went to went back to school my
mom
had his back she was handing she had
that
and my dad whenever my mom was more
difficult this and that
health or whatever whatnot my dad had
that
he had the back so whenever someone
comes out to me and be like you know
what hey yo
thanks for that sorry about it i got
your back and your friend
because that's what it is we it would be
nice like in a couple that we normalized
whenever you come out of a hard [ __ ] and
things getting
things are gonna get easier and when
things are getting there
you're like yo by the way
back then when it was hard yo you did
that yeah high five
yeah we it would be good to normalize
that i know it's like a kind of
utopian world and i'm telling you like i
know like am i the way i'm thinking
about that people think that i'm soft or
whatever what not and maybe it's just
the way that i was brought up because my
think was really equal
and i remember when i was at the
freshman fit uh
podcast and i was talking about my
parents and i was like yo i saw my
pencil
and people was like yo that's cap that's
cap that's cap
it just dawned on me that it was so not
the case for people
that they couldn't even understand that
that could be a possibility
yeah but you see my parents you see what
they you've seen what they have
yeah yeah and you know they're saying
sometimes people operate too much in a
binary so you already know which one
that one
you already know i'm with you on that
one uh i feel like it's just super
unfortunate
i spent a good solid part of an hour
just listening to everyone talk
and i was rolling my eyes so heavy you
know some of them are young women so
it's like you know maybe they got time
to grow and learn
but some of the other ones just like so
stubborn and send their ways and so like
struggling
yeah and it's just like do you not
learn from your failures if i dated the
same way at 30 today that i did at 21
bro you could comfortably look at me and
say [ __ ] you're never going to be with
somebody
the reason why i'm not stressing is
because i've seen the evolution i've
seen the change
whether it be in how i have sex whether
it be in how i date whether it be how i
work
our work relationship has improved yeah
definitely because you know
sorry go ahead yeah go ahead no no no no
go ahead but you weren't talking yeah
i'm going to go out for a long time so
just go for it
no go ahead you know but um essentially
just saying like
because of the lessons i've learned i've
had to have that evolution
and i hope that people also do that in
their own life and stop blaming the
world around them
for the reasons why they're not finding
the people that they want and understand
that the
answers often lie within you
often lie within you would you imagine
if people had these juvenile dreams i
want to be an astronaut
and they're almost 45 and not working
out at some point it's okay to say
settle you know there's plenty people
who wanted to be an engineer
and sometimes they become a pe teacher
and they're super happy at their pe
teaching job
contributing paying bills taking care of
their family
and working with kids settling does not
have to be
this end-all-be-all terrible thing but
when it comes to dating we act like oh
my god
you're gonna live a life of misery guys
it's okay to humble yourself
yeah but i think does it mean that
you're trash people
think of giving up when they think about
settling when you say that word that's
what people
think that's what i mean that is the
definition
of settling in their head that's why
they don't even want to have something
close to that
they want everything life is supposed to
be sex in the city
yep like it's supposed to be all that
all those standards that you see in
those
whack ass hope oprah's and stuff like
that you know
so that that's really what they want and
last thing that i got to say about this
it's crazy because in the world people
say that women mature faster than men
and i see this and i'm like
not necessarily it depends we mature
differently
depends where the depends where the only
thing i would say is like listen ladies
if you guys want to be wise i think you
guys
should definitely do a lot of your due
diligence to understand what it means to
be a wife and what's necessary
and also what's necessary from your
husband okay necessary not what you want
what's necessary
and then if these things aren't
necessary but you still need them as
desires
i think you have to start to separate
what's needed and what's not
because if you guys are stopping
yourself from getting married because of
things that are not
necessary to a marriage then you guys
are going to be shortchanging yourself a
lot of opportunities
things that will not contribute to your
success if you make those the
cornerstones of why you will not be with
somebody you will limit
it's like trying to start a company and
saying you won't hire employees because
they wear red shoes on sundays it's like
some of this stuff has nothing to do
with with longevity with somebody and i
think a lot of you guys right now
are especially young so it's fine but as
you get older and i'm telling you man
yo i talked to some people and the
desperation that they show and some of
the sadness that exists is just like
i don't wish that for nobody whether
it's man or a woman so just just think
about those things and understand what
it is that you want for your future
and and just keep that in mind okay and
this is where like most of our mission
comes from
you know i find it so crazy when people
like y'all hate women it's like
man i get i get so happy for people when
they find people
when you talk people who are in
relationships a lot of them like and
they want to be there
you see how much of a burden is lifted
you know what i'm saying yeah definitely
you know people who are in it and want
to be in it got somebody who's
supportive it's not always easy it's not
always ideal
but they you can tell they're doing good
they're doing good for themselves and
they're content in that and so for us
it's just
it's just these are the lessons that
they had to learn
you feel me and i think a lot of couples
who are
doing good for themselves aren't
oftentimes divulging
that information to the people who are
or if they are the people who aren't in
those
situations don't want to believe it
definitely you know like when we put out
the videos
so many people got the comments man my
partner maybe had 60
of what i thought i wanted but now now
i'm so much happier than i ever thought
i could be
it's like of course you would be
shocked how much you will like your life
when you humble yourself yeah so
so so i i just hope that people don't
watch this stuff and think like oh
hey bro this is a complete opposite if
y'all thrive and y'all feel happy i'm
ecstatic
and if you don't listen to us and you're
happy and you're good with your life i'm
ecstatic
because the truth is a lot of y'all hit
us up and you guys are like i'm not good
with it
and and sometimes it's linked to this
and and that's all that we're trying to
get it
that must have been painful for you but
whatever yeah being around those ladies
yeah yeah
yeah for sure for sure you know me if i
was there oh yeah why would that
what would happen if it was you what do
you think would have happened
i don't know i'm asking you it would
have been it's just in the delivery
the delivery wouldn't be so poised
i wouldn't be you know you're common
you're people think that you're very
dismissive
that you're very rough and
raw in some instances i can't understand
where they cut when that come where that
come from but
if i was there at that point with those
ladies yeah you would have definitely
gone further than me
oh yeah definitely going in
for petty mode but you know what i
thought i would have said the same thing
but the delivery would have been
different and it would have been i
wouldn't call them names or whatever
but the way i try to prove my point to
people is it's petty sometimes and
whether
this wouldn't be the difference you know
i mean yeah but but you know what though
i also say like people meet me in person
like you're really chilling and pretty
quiet to your surf i'm like
yeah and you're polite i'm like i know
i just chill in my corner i'm not here
to take up space or do anything
but i also won't back down like [ __ ]
will say that when i was on the podcast
and off the podcast
he kept the same energy people like yeah
but you came on the podcast and you came
with a smoke it's not that
it's like you were saying some [ __ ]
about me so let's just talk about it
yeah i'm not afraid of confrontation
but i'm also gonna come like in the
violent like [ __ ] what it wasn't like
that i was like oh you had these ideas
let's discuss them
in a civil manner and and you could do
that to some people that smoke
yeah but to some people me saying so was
that [ __ ] you was talking about
yeah i know with the lego it can sound
like i'm coming in
no but let's go let's discuss it let's
talk it let's talk what's that [ __ ]
cause you was talking some [ __ ]
let's talk about it we'll discuss about
it ain't nothing gonna happen ain't
we're gonna pop off or whatever what not
but we're gonna talk about it so what
that [ __ ] was talking about yeah
[Music]
i